>> Bret: JOHN ROBERTS LIVE ON
THE NORTH LAWN, THANK YOU.
THE LATEST ON THE COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS SCANDAL.
THE SECOND OF THE TWO FAMOUS
ACTRESSES INVOLVED IN ALLEGEDLY
TRYING TO PAY BRIBES TO GET
THEIR CHILDREN INTO AN ELITE
UNIVERSITY HAS SURRENDERED TO
AUTHORITIES TONIGHT.
WE ARE LEARNING MORE ABOUT AN
INTRICATE AND HUGELY EXPENSIVE
SCHEME.
MOLLY LINE IS 11 BOSTON PORT
TONIGHT WITH THE LATEST.
GOOD EVENING.
>> AS HE
MENTIONED THIS CONTINUES AS ONE
OF THE MOST RECOGNIZABLE PARENTS
WHO HAS NARRATED THIS MASSIVE
SCHEME GOING BEFORE THE JUDGE.
LORI LOUGLIN, FULL HOUSE FAME
WAS TAKEN INTO CUSTODY BY FBI
AGENTS WERE JUST GETTING BORED
OUT OF COURT THAT THE JUDGE SAYS
SHE WILL BE FREE ON A $1 MILLION
BOND.
THIS IS IN DOWNTOWN L.A. AND SHE
FACES MAIL AND WIRE FRAUD
CHARGES.
>> THEY STAND ACCUSED OF PAYING
$500 IN BRIBES TO HAVE THEIR
DAUGHTER DESIGNATED AS A
RECRUIT TO THE CREW TEAM AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
EVEN CEMENTING A PICTURE OF ONE
DAUGHTER ON AN INDOOR ROWING
MACHINE.
SO THE GIRLS NOT PARTICIPATE AND
CREW.
OTHERS ALSO FAKED THE CHILD'S
ATHLETIC PROWESS BY JOINT
PHOTOS.
THEY SHOW ONE EXECUTIVE PAID
BRIBES TO HAVE THEIR SON
PRESENTED AS A TALENTED POOL OF
ALTER THEIR DAUGHTER AS A TENNIS
RECRUIT.
THE FOUNDER OF A FOOD AND
BEVERAGE COMPANY PAID UNDER
25,000 TO HAVE A TALENTED
TEST-TAKER TO THE S.A.T. AND ACT
FOR THEIR DAUGHTER TO GET INTO
DUKE.
ONE WEALTHY LAWYER PAID $75,000
FOR PROCTOR TO CORRECT
DAUGHTER'S ANSWERS.
MAGAZINE OPERATOR PAID HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS TO FABRICATE
BASKETBALL CREDENTIALS ON HIS
DAUGHTER'S BEHALF.
FELICITY HOFFMAN OF DESPERATE
HOUSEWIVES STANDS ACCUSED TO
HAVE THOSE ANSWERS SECRETLY
CORRECTED.
DOZENS OF WEALTHY PARENTS
FUNNELED MONEY TO AND THROUGH
THE MASSIVE MASTERMIND OF THE
SCHEME, WILLIAM SINGER.
HE PLED GUILTY TO RACKETEERING
CONSPIRACY AND OTHER CHARGES AND
FEDERAL COURT IN BOSTON
YESTERDAY.
HER DAUGHTER, A RISING
SOCIAL MEDIA START FACED
BACKLASH FOR ONE PRIOR POSTING.
>> I WANT THE EXPERIENCE OF GAME
DAY PARTYING, I DON'T REALLY
CARE ABOUT SCHOOL.
AS YOU GUYS WILL KNOW.
>> SHE LATER BACKTRACKED
TWEETING, AND EDUCATION IS ALSO
SUPER IMPORTANT TO ME.
PROSECUTORS HAD DECLINED TO
CHARGE STUDENTS.
SOME OF WHOM WERE UNAWARE OF THE
SCHEME.
THEY COULD FACE CONSEQUENCES,
TODAY THEY RELEASED A STATEMENT
NOTING THAT APPLICANTS CONNECTED
TO THE SCHEME WILL BE DENIED
ADMISSION.
THEY SAID A CASE-BY-CASE REVIEW
FOR CURRENT STUDENTS AND
GRADUATES WILL BE CONDUCTED
WARNING OF APPROPRIATE DECISIONS
TO COME.
HE SCANDAL IS HEADING IN ENTER
UPON CAMPUSES.
>> ANY STUDENT WHO DESERVES TO
GET INTO WORK VERY HARD.
>> BETSY DeVOS WAY DANCING
STUDENTS SHOULD BE CONSIDERED ON
THEIR MERITS.
>> OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OPERATION,
BUT WE ARE LOOKING VERY CLOSELY
AT IT AND WE WILL SEE IF ANY OF
THE REGULATIONS THAT WE ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR HAVE BEEN BROKE
BROKEN.
>> THIS CONTINUES IN A COURT
APPEARANCE IN BOSTON, THEY ARE
JUST BEGINNING.
SEVERAL FOLKS WHO MAKE A
CROSS-COUNTRY FLIGHT SOON,
HOFFMAN AND OTHERS APPEARED IN